Sarah Huckabee Sanders the Republican
governor of Arkansas was selected to
deliver the response to Joe Biden's
State of the Union Address last night
maybe the most disgusting and delusional
State of the Union response that I have
ever seen and by the way being given by
someone whose state is a disaster now
it's not an ad hominem when I say
Arkansas is a disaster it is uh
empirically a disaster it is the seventh
worst state in the country in terms of
places to raise a family 45th for health
and safety in the five worst states for
violent crime per capita 47th in infant
mortality 41st in education 41st in the
economy the state is a disaster and
Sarah Huckabee Sanders is spending time
and resources on things like for example
Banning the teaching of critical race
theory in Arkansas Public Schools which
wasn't being taught anyway and she is
selected to deliver the response okay we
knew it would be a big anti-woke party
and indeed Sarah Huckabee Sanders starts
her response speech basically by calling
Biden a liar and she knows a lot about
lying that's for sure she was Trump's
press secretary for a while three
good evening I'm Sarah Huckabee Sanders
we know being a mom to three young
children taught me not to believe every
story I hear
so forgive me for not believing much of
anything I heard tonight from President
Biden from out of control inflation and
violent crime remember violent crime
trending down inflation down six months
in a row to the dangerous border crisis
and threat from China remember that
nothing has substantively changed with
border policy from Trump to Biden the
China thing is sort of like an amorphous
one
Biden and the Democrats have failed you
they know it and you know it nothing
really factual there but an interesting
way to start she then goes really hard
into the woke stuff claiming listen we
got sucked into this culture where we
didn't want it which is quite a bit of
revisionist history and while you read
the consequences of their failures
registration seems more
face every day
most Americans simply want to live their
lives in Freedom and peace
but we are under attack in a left-wing
culture War we didn't start and never
wanted to fight hard to imagine a bigger
lie than that Republicans realizing they
were failing on policy and that the
country was turning on them on just
about every issue decided we are no
longer going to fight for policy we're
just going to fight the culture War this
is quite literally the opposite of the
truth every day we are told we must
partake in their rituals salute their
flags and worship their false Idols all
while big government colludes with big
Tech to strip away the most American
thing there is ah your freedom of speech
another dog whistle that they use
endlessly to point the finger at all
sorts of different parties over people's
supposed speech being taken away when it
is not now Sarah Huckabee Sanders did
say one thing I agree with she meant it
differently but she said that the
dividing line is now between normal and
crazy I agree with that I disagree with
her about which side is crazy the
dividing line in America is no longer
between bride or left
the choice is between normal
or crazy true it's time for a new
generation of Republican leadership
upon taking office just a few weeks ago
I signed executive orders to ban CRT
racism and indoctrination in our schools
now remember CRT is not being taught in
Arkansas schools however Arkansas is
still at the bottom of the list in terms
of Education out of 50 States but that's
how she chose to use her time as
governor and resources
um let's go to the very end of this
disgusting speech Sarah Huckabee Sanders
ending it with a painful looking Grimace
look at this thank you God bless you and
God bless America
yeah
um
following the theme of the Republican
party for the last six eight ten twelve
years
absolutely no meaningful substantive
policy for just everyday people who work
or who want to work or who used to work
but became disabled or whatever it's
it's none of that just culture War
dog whistles
anti-wokeness and a focus on issues that
aren't even really issues and of course
completely straw Manning the totality of
Joe Biden's speech maybe the most vile
State of the Union response that I have
ever seen from an individual who is
quite frankly one of the most vile
participants in American politics that I
can recall over the last 10 to 20 years
you might remember that a few years ago
uh the show got hacked and many
thousands of dollars were stolen we
never got it back it's a terrible
feeling it can happen to anyone but a
couple of years ago we got Aura which
really gives us significantly more peace
of mind and our sponsor Aura is the app
that protects you from scammers by
alerting you anytime your info like
email passwords social security number
are found in data breaches or also
automatically requests removal of your
info from search engines and it can
reduce spam calls Aura alerts you
quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try or a free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below